very patient clear today we were playing
the board game operation drunk versus
high played years ago probably sites
like sophomore year of high school the
last time I played was in middle school
so it's time to get drunk it's time to
get high and we're gonna be surgeons is
it for 20
well it's for 20 in our hearts and it's
five o'clock somewhere okay so we are
drunken high high thing and now we are
going to play the game botched operation
botched operation don't get buzzed you
got really fun yeah this is a guy I
still think he needs like a haircut
I hope my bones are never like this yeah
oh there's a battery pack it's a battery
family be doubly very the junk girl
always provides games we need a
screwdriver next I don't I can't pull
screwdriver can I use my now you can try
don't break your nail don't do it
so we pretty much puts the game together
well I didn't really help DJ and our
wonderful team and now we're gonna play
the rule is we get five buzzes and then
we're out I pretty much watch DJ put
this together so I know that I'm gonna
fail let's get started then okay here
first
first of all I didn't wear my glasses so
I'm blind
gypsies hell you got it you got it
damn I got nails on cuz I'm trying to be
cute all right let's get those 1 buzz my
turn my turn I didn't even get this crap
out there's so many options don't choose
this one cuz that's the demon I was
waiting for the heart but they call me
the heart breaker the heart is not even
on the skin thing it's like in there
no all right oh do the butterfly that
was a bad choice why would I go for that
one because so far neither many which is
lit that's the point way to say we were
both trash no that's true so why I got
one I have a zero this is probably
pretty bad let's do this either you are
king amongst mortals you are amazing
we're gonna get this patient home okay
right they say anymore
I am sweating uh let's go for the nuts
Oh straight for it oh she won again let
me to zero to zero all right go for one
that you could be very common with no
way too long in this come on oh my god
Joyce is like the best cheerleader
Oh DJ don't flinch oh my god I had
flinching you're flinching I'm kind of
like to throw it you're so I'm like way
out of time I'm just gonna do this until
I get it because I deserve this I did
let's go let's do it all right she's
still winning though oh I'm sorry
okay that one's hard that was hard not
the shape of the Capitals rubber band
out oh never mind
accounts its accountant and job with
surgeons we just got to get it done so
our thing is marina won four to one
[Music]
you give me that Ruffy wait Joyce you're
so good at this I don't understand how
you're so good at this it's 2:00 to 4:00
Joyce out here stopping me no it's just
because I'm only good in life and death
situations it's not like an impossible
angle right there it is it's like it's
like I got a mess you up to make you
better you know what I'm saying
everybody I'm just supposed to sit here
and watch you die it's not my job to
watch you die well I'll Drive it make
you less you got a choice I can't listen
to the haters it's weird because I'm not
supposed to touch the edges I'm a demon
oh you got it oh my shot one more time
last try last try five-o knows right yes
pick it up the riot this isn't long
enough it's so close
excuse me after drunkenly burp nice you
got this you're their DJ just get that
in get that in yes DJ DJ DJ dude AG
there oh wait wait wait wait
got it got it got it let's go and I got
three literally
we help the patients me and my team
member Mike squad this will actually is
a little pretty fun game it's still fun
I don't like that every level was a
little more than it needed to be what
are we doing this next okay let's get
little game
[Music]